[Music]
hey guys welcome back to whatever the
[ __ ] whatever the [ __ ] we want to that's
the new song for it
you know yesterday my mom came over and
we're just hanging out having a good
time and then random issues like huh
what the hell you have a tattoo that's
what we're talking about she was like
when did you get a tattoo on your arm
yeah and I'm like I've been having a
shift for years I think your mom's for
having a mental problem yeah do you
think maybe she's getting it I don't
know she was like I know about the one
above the elbow what about the one below
the elbow like I've seen you about a
thousand times already like I don't know
when I got this but it's got to be over
five years ago tell it or go into the
YouTube and just backtrack and then
she'll see exactly the you that it
happened yeah well we should just start
off with their mom dancing did almost
guarantee you I am about a hundred
thousand of those views interesting
person what five more videos on my
always the same song is that her
favorite song no it's just the same day
or the same day I was playing different
music for her it's not even the dancing
that gets me is that she danced so
[ __ ] hard she had to take a nap yeah
it was good I want to hire her to go go
dance and what's funniest when she when
she naps she poses - so yesterday she
was playing with Tiger hella hard like
she's like running back and forth and
she started getting tired so she goes on
the couch it she's just like she gets
the pillows and she's just like this so
now you imagine the old Asian lady with
like a visor on she's just watching
that's how he remembers her always she
didn't know if I should - I had or
something something with the bill she
had a hat yeah
fine so ham she gets so happy at that
time control crazy - like when tyka just
like he cries a little bit as he was
getting hungry then she you guys have
heard her high-pitched voice yeah
anxious
and then there's a crybaby crybaby
and I'm like oh my god I did great
it's white like you'll say and you know
[ __ ] yeah it's wild yesterday she was
like what did she say she was like oh do
I look more healthy to you I don't she
goes do I salary harder to you and I'm
like she's never been quite she gets
manageable uh yeah but but you never
been quiet one did you know that fool
said he's leaving social media for you
that was the most impulsive he was like
okay everybody you know of the girl that
I love she does not like social media so
I'm leaving and it was like not even
like like six hours later he comes back
maybe it's not a good idea because I get
famous he used to do vine okay when vine
was really popular the way I found him
was just he just showed up one day and
then he was practicing English and it
was the most hilarious thing ever
because he would be like oh this is a PO
I like Apple very good very nice I like
it
so is he funny without even realizing
that people are kind of yeah making fun
of him still doesn't know he thinks like
he's the [ __ ] he thinks people just like
him it's not even like it's not even
like being conceited he just I think he
joins the interaction yeah like if it
was him like he like really dug himself
I promised he'll watch it but I wouldn't
like him as much yeah but it's just so
innocent
it's very innocent like but he talks
about his date like his relationship
with his parents and all that [ __ ] in
China this was Chinese his [ __ ] China
as a mother like he's not like typical
Chinese I think he may be a little slow
that's all thinking I think it's like
northern Chinese there
or like he's like socially awkward as
hell you know I mean like he has some
kind of like social inability like it's
I don't know I feel like he can't read
the room sweet overshares
yeah can you were to meet us for the
first time yesterday like off and touch
my wiener
like okay [ __ ] like it did but when
he's happy though yeah you feel vege
it's like pure joy happiness okay crazy
that when actors that one viral and she
was going what's her name she's super
fans the white girl Oh
[Music]
motivational I like that motivational
black made on Twitter that toxic on oh
yes don't let okay you do you babe it
because all those other people like have
you seen those videos no it's just her
head so sounds like a regular day of my
parents door to meet in ways like a
puppet show she's just this record like
Moses actually reports her hands she's
like I just want to tell you that you
are beautiful and you don't need these
other feet like she's just so on to no
face no it's literally like this I've
never seen a face yeah sometimes
so and her nails are a long as [ __ ]
issues clicks at you yeah she's like the
most positive person ever like ever I
look I never liked it when girls had the
Dracula nails I love my only reason why
I don't have them nails cuz I have to
play video games
otherwise I would have them [ __ ]
right now no instead of going to therapy
and getting a psychologist to help you
we need to just hire very motivational
black women to and every morning to pick
us up and say some like positive ass
[ __ ] pick you up like how like your
little and there
I'll pick up your spirits but you know
what it does I kind of like them to pick
you up like a baby but I feel that
beautiful today not to just because like
in the in the first part of my life I
only attended Korean church right and
then the the other half of my life I
went to like a majority at like a black
church and even like cultural
differences and like how people like
pick each other up it's way different
you know Koreans go you stupid but I
like the way they greet you at church
and how they talk to you and how I
developed a lot of friends with people
these church was way different like I
think like crazy or whatever you know
but then like when when when I was at
the black church like they could make
you feel good about anything it was like
wild to me you know I mean it's like you
would walk into life baby is that a new
shirt okay and I'm like yeah it is but
it's just like it's like that type of
like warmth that you get I think like
like that's like that
that thing I liked about black culture
growing up as a kid so much cuz I grew
up around it so much there's that when
they're on your side they hype you up
it's like it's good it feels amazing
it's I like that warm feeling of when an
old black lady calls you baby oh it's so
cute and then when I think of Korean
churches I just think of my son is now a
lawyer he makes Korean grandmas are like
super nurturing that's why I really like
that like so like it's so funny too
because when i we at the church was over
they would have korean food right oh it
was because i'm said i was such a huge
fat kid they would put in food i mean
they would look up they go oh this kind
is morning yeah you got so much it's
like they know they know the field they
gotta [ __ ] feel this rocket baby come
on now [ __ ] I encountered
something the other day that pissed me
off - no [ __ ] end rocket and then
he's like oh yes if you were to see
character you'd be baymax and make
everyone happy
hey max not anymore you got to freaking
I like babe and out I know they were
skinny now skinny eyes David changed man
you're not the same anymore you don't
care to hug you you notice that you come
in I'm like Oh David one arm that's a
lot my self-esteem was so [ __ ] high I
didn't realize how out of shape I was
until I see videos yeah I mean because I
still feel the same and you look at it
like damn man I used to be fat you know
I was watching that video when we're a
Smorgasburg uh-huh and we were doing the
teaching dog look oh yeah I was like yo
that guy looks gross but like I didn't
notice that because every day was just
it was just today you know you just kind
of like go about it the only thing I did
feel is physically I feel better but
like in the sense of like looking at
myself in the mirror I still feel the
same but like I could move faster I
could you know I had more energy how
much do you weigh now I weigh 215 so I
started that I started at 260 Wow yeah
so like Dave be almost like 45 pounds so
I have like another I want to be at 185
190 that might be too much bro that
might be too much he wants to be a pro
my Thai fighter I wouldn't be able to
just like it your head's too big for
that weight though right though your
heads will be immune for the decimal did
I say that I said that to you no no no
muscle to hold it up does it
I should be fine it's got a weight trade
and then hopefully it'll be like 190 ish
of like good solid muscle okay I'm gonna
tell you guys last week there is
something that pissed me off so much
remember the video of the [ __ ]
Chinese [ __ ] holding a parking spot
yeah happened to me in downtown LA and I
was [ __ ] pissed I was on my way
jogging it was like in the heart of
downtown and I was looking for parking
because we were doing an escape room
where there was like no other spots it
was all like Street parking and I see
these like I see a spot I pull and
there's these two dudes standing there
I'm like so I roll down my window my
what are you doing he goes we're saving
the spot to Chinese dudes a white dude
[ __ ] you know [ __ ] ya know better and
then it just part of the [ __ ] Chinese
people and I did you party there anyways
I couldn't move just run him over I
remember reading them illegal yeah
richer I told him like you can't do that
that's illegal then he goes he goes well
I'm gonna [ __ ] hold it anyway what are
you gonna do
[ __ ] you you fight for for ass [ __ ] and
then I drove off so [ __ ] pissed I was
like why there's two of you five foot
four [ __ ] and OJ was a five foot four
guy walking across the street like hey
yeah I was by myself
it was so [ __ ] annoying I've never
been so pissed and I know that if I were
to park there anyways your card get my
car would get [ __ ] up I was so mad
what are you supposed to do can you hit
them I wanted to so bad happen if you
start it slowly moving in and tapping
their body with your car like they can
go under they'd be like oh insurance
let's see this is why you have a Honda
Element you understand they could jump
on the hand start beating on it just
drive a shitty ass [ __ ] dirty with so
much bird [ __ ] you gotta ruin all their
clothes that's true yeah yeah okay so if
I had a shitty car I would've done that
like [ __ ] up my car then who cares
that's true it is lose-lose because like
let's say you get out of the car you
step to them they get all scared to go
away you parked your car they'll come
back in the pile [ __ ] on a Kia whatever
that's wrong what if you just wait for
the car that they're away where they
mock your car a car that's true that's
true but if you get in trouble for
[ __ ] up a car I was by myself and I
wish I had like you guys with me you
know if you guys thought I used to do it
was pretty fun I wouldn't have fought
them I'm not gonna beat up two gay guys
they weren't gay well that's a gay move
that they did if he dropped it if you
drop his booty and he did - that's
because that's sassy you know that's
like I'm gonna say hey I also assume
that they're gay because you're a very
attractive lady why would they do that
to a hot day they were [ __ ] dude like
if I did that I was like this is my spot
and she goes hey I'm like oh my bad
y'all
now let's say for you many one of them
was a little [ __ ] it didn't say
anything and the other one she's like
well I'm going to stand here take this
bet I feel like they have really
controlling girlfriends that are like
you better [ __ ] get out the cards
they be like but honey
like that's illegal because you better
[ __ ] do what you got to do is get
those like long like Nine Inch Nails and
then and then spike it into the bottom
of their car and so when they roll when
they roll out it actually starts to leak
out all their air I used to do this [ __ ]
all the time you would walk around with
[ __ ] names I just have really bad
temper you know I mean I used to keep
cars all the [ __ ] time you know when
you dig into the paint and you [ __ ] this
great anyone I do I do
I like they pissed me off but then for
me to like hurt him that much I'm like I
can't [ __ ] do it I just little bit
they deserve I don't like key cars
because I don't like the feeling of it
that's why oh wait what am I talking
about some ear dog [ __ ] on your car do
you have a fancy car that's the first
time I ever encounter that I didn't
think people actually [ __ ] did that
they do it if it was a mainland Chinese
it's like all right well everyone knows
your [ __ ] you know I think we've
probably done it a couple times what you
and I we did it once but then the police
officer talked to me once oh oh no sobs
ah ah
you know Garfield in Maine or that
that's why I learn so I was holding in
the spot and this guy pulls up and he is
like hey you can't save the spot and I'm
like yes I can I'm saving a spot for
micro fees gonna turn back around the
controlling girlfriend yeah you're right
in there so he pee get out of the car I
was always sure about to throw down
right now and he goes excuse me sir I
just let you know I am off-duty police
officer and shows me a spatula what
you're doing is illegal and I was like
[ __ ] that bad okay [ __ ] just wants to be
up oh you're a cop
well then sorry okay babe I can't
this any other time and like you start
beating up geo in front of your [ __ ]
tell you actually she was the one that
was like sorry hey you know this is
illegal right now don't you
oh yeah you don't do it's gonna be a
legal night I'll save us a spot my smell
legal if this was any other time and
like I usually have no [ __ ] to do at all
and I had all the time in the world I
would do sat there and call the cops but
I was already late to my escape room but
I wanted to call they start on time yeah
exactly
you got to do some creative ass [ __ ]
though if I try to save a parking spot I
would just pretend that there's an
invisible shield there yeah I can't
escape I would be so bad but so
entertained what if you lose weight like
full-on crazy like just screaming right
when they say somebody just go crazy and
scare this don't like that parking spot
then right are you pretty crazy if
you're just doing this though oh I've
been in for 30 days please water please
water please
I said rocking on the floor to you they
just like it security guard in the
corners like these foes are [ __ ]
crazy there's always a guy at the
[ __ ] hat here like a giant star I
make seen some [ __ ] they're like is not
worth me [ __ ] getting into it I
notice now that a lot of people send me
photos I should have their baby and I
just don't give a [ __ ] unless it's tiger
or Leia like oh thank you thank you I
send you a foot like what videos like
you baby I'm like your baby's [ __ ]
ugly I never said oh no I have like I
love when you send me stuff you know and
it's like those are the two babies that
give a [ __ ] about everyone else go [ __ ]
myself oh so then they think that you
guys are friends yeah I don't know why
[Music]
[Laughter]
but I think I don't care unless his head
it's [ __ ] like a basketball like
taike or small your golf ball like Leia
I mean I just send you pictures of my
future kid oh [ __ ] he's too big right
now no not a baby anymore my friends
here I care about it's fine like this
this group is fine everyone else that
fools head last night and I thought I'd
be able to close my fingers and I can't
know I was like this and there's like
inches I'm like do we can you wear my
hats now is a big [ __ ] big dude he's
like baby juggernaut juggernaut did I
just like watching the Instagram videos
because Tyga is literally a drunk person
at a bachelor party yes cracks me up did
and then when he was in the toy box his
legs are dangling a raccoon and she
garbage can cracking the [ __ ] up dude
this thing right now he likes jumping in
so now he knows how to get off of the
couch he likes to take more steps now so
I feel like any day now he's just gonna
be doing his own thing and walking to do
like 10 or 12 yes yes with that and then
the other do you think barely touches
the couch once dude he runs and he's
like using this as a reference and then
he likes to jump into his old boy basket
that's the record a friend of mine told
me that like they were really happy
about their kid learn
on a walk but he said like the moment
they started walking that's when they
started by acting like a little [ __ ]
because now they have willpower to go
where they want to go and if you tell
them that's where they're like it's a
dropping it [ __ ] oh oh you did that last
night remember on a permanent high chair
okay so usually like when I put him in
the hydrilla he knows it's time to eat
so he just flops right this is like lint
this time let me get another chair the
way he's doing it Ellis I got you to
pick me up for a second I was trying to
sit him down the minute his feet touched
a little stirrup to go like 30 times I
just kept putting on my you
[ __ ] at this time if they grab
both of his bottom ankles fold them in
half and stick his ass in it first and
then strap him in and then he was like
alright fine I think he's learning that
like if he doesn't want to do something
he could not do so I can't wait to tell
you speaks that I'm like if you don't do
what I want you to do I'm gonna [ __ ]
do it myself [ __ ] any other oh
[ __ ] not gonna do that
yes our right side is you wearing right
now 18 months sighs playing shoes 10 G's
that's a big [ __ ] Jesus Christ
dude that's insane yeah big massive
muscle guys just [ __ ] big she's hella
strong too every time he grabs my hair
like no he's no longer allowed to touch
my face he scratched my face last time
he [ __ ] cut my cheek right here I was
like no more what are you guys gonna
have kids [ __ ] never yeah I I would
like to have a kid but apparently right
now if you guys would take care of them
what about Jess she doesn't have a say
in it no but what if we want to go
somewhere you're supposed to take away
Kate these parents came over for the
weekend and we asked his mom were like
cuz we asked her before she was like oh
you know I'll stay with you made for a
couple weeks or whatever but then this
time I asked her again and then she was
like well I'll stay as long as you guys
want like until you come yeah
so I was like what she's a gang you know
I'll just fly back to Dallas like once a
week once a month
every like for a week yeah no Mike what
so cool she'll probably live with us
once we have our kids see and she's
still young and she's still healthy my
mom's an old ass [ __ ]
those are the best ones I'm tired yeah
those are the best ones because they're
on the same schedule each other together
oh that's cute
my mom's always trying to go on [ __ ]
cruises and [ __ ] we live the Love Boat
if I were to have kids and I left him
with my dad I think my dad like start
throwing him around chucking around the
room mission there's like [ __ ] like
animal [ __ ] all over him because they
just hang out the animals have fun and
then your baby's gonna go like this
see mommy let me see your nails oh no my
dad the next day I come back he's a
[ __ ] pure chop on his face now oh my
gosh and he does nails real good those
nails real quick - my dad has he said
giant blue - thinking he does nails and
he's like tattoos all over in five weeks
I Bluetooth for oh do you take some
phone calls in business oh okay okay
he's one who picks up and [ __ ] okay
so I feel like if I were to drop them
now hello you wanna quit no jail really
crazy story okay so I was talking to
Mike I was talking to my my parents
right if their own speaker will never
like late we talked together and then my
dad's like did mom tell you about the
fight and I was like oh my god dad what
did you do he get and then moms like no
no no it wasn't a fight with us your dad
got into a fight
oh I was like what okay so I was like
wait he's like did you [ __ ] did you tell
her which one I'm like there's more than
one fight so the first fight he was at
his shop and then there was like this
lady that walked past the glass and she
was like screaming no no and there's a
guy following her he's I get the [ __ ]
back here it was her boyfriend or
whatever and then like he went over and
he kicked her and my dad kicked there
like a chicken yeah you kicked chickens
when they're chasing you roosters
yeah wait what
long story short my dad like kicked his
ass and held him down so the cops came
nice second time was they went to an
adult prom because they're [ __ ] cute
and [ __ ] they do all those cute [ __ ]
together and then my dad brings his guy
over to the table and then he goes he
goes this my wife introduce yourself and
then the guy goes hi my name is butt and
then my dad's wife grabbed his hand
shakes it but I goes and then and then I
was like dad why did you do that so
apparently my dad went to the bathroom
there was these two guys talking which
is that one guy and his friend was
telling me dude why are you grabbing
these girl's asses for no reason you
don't know who they are yeah creepy I
was like well cuz I could I'm not gonna
[ __ ] do [ __ ] to me my dad heard that
and then so the friend was like dude you
can't just touch women that's not okay
and the dudes I gotta [ __ ] whatever so
my dad heard that he's like hey come
here right now he he he grabbed the
guy's hand dragged him over to my mom
and he needed a reason to beat the dude
up cuz he touched his wife yeah so
that's why introduce yourself and the
moment he touched my mom's hand he
smacked it and he goes you don't ever
[ __ ] you don't ever [ __ ] touch
women like that you hear me goodbye okay
he runs off man you're supposed to
mellow out when you're older what he
would have done like when he was younger
it's just murdered him in the bathroom
exactly mellow and I'm like dad that's a
true refugee man yeah don't do the
[ __ ] on me like that was and I was
like I can't even be mad at that cuz
that's the smartest thing I've ever
heard like there's like levels of
questions you asked when suddenly I have
so let's say like Maryland now we're at
that adult promise somebody goes like
whether this guy touched me the first
thing I said what the [ __ ] how big is he
question number one then you figure out
the rest is your dad a big dude no like
that doesn't give a [ __ ] he's he's five
foot six oh we're like the same height
you don't give a [ __ ]
[Music]